here's your money briefing for Wednesday
March 22nd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank and
concerns over the health of the broader
banking sector have reintroduced the
idea of putting Banks through a stress
test to gauge their ability to operate
during a hypothetical emergency so how
would you do a similar top to bottom
checkup with your own personal finances
Jeff rogo is a Wall Street Journal
editor who works with our personal
finance team and he joins me with more
hey Jeff thanks very much for being with
us thank you for having me so Jeff when
we hear the term stress test as it
pertains to Banks what does that usually
entail so every year the Federal Reserve
takes the largest banks in the country
and provides a disaster preparedness
situation so it looks at what if we lose
X percent of jobs what if there's
freezes in the credit market and looks
at what happens in these scenarios to
Banks finances their Capital ratios
their funding how strong are their
situation if a bunch of bad stuff
happens and at the end they all get a
grade alright so why is now a good time
to put your own personal finances
through a similar test over the last two
weeks or so everyone's kind of freaked
out because one enormous Bank in
California has failed another large Bank
in Europe had to be bought and a bunch
of regional Banks were under pressure
you're seeing these headlines and your
response may be to freak out and your
response may be I don't care it doesn't
affect me I don't think either of these
are the right responses your response is
to do something and what you can do is
stress test your own finances and I
think there's concrete ways they can go
about and see am I okay if there's my
own personal sort of bad bad situation
so let's go through that test a lot of
people do their banking they might have
their savings their mortgage their car
loan even their small business finances
at one institution wouldn't that make it
easy to run their money through a test
it's a convenient as a consumer so as a
consumer having all of your stuff in one
place is really easy it's one app it
also is probably what the bank has been
telling you you know since the financial
crisis one of the big thing banks have
done is this idea of cross-selling let's
get a customer in the door and by doing
that we can offer them all these other
products so what that enables you as a
customer is probably a little easier to
do a stress test but what you don't know
is the health of that singular
institution and so even if on all those
lines you look great know that you're
still tied to One Financial firm there
are banks that have passed stress tests
and failed if you have that much money
with one institution even if you feel
really comfortable about your own
finances you are still running a risk
and so for that all the financial
advisors we talked to even the bankers
we talked to said just don't put all
your eggs in one basket have checking
account maybe another place have maybe a
small business loan another place and
the issue we had with Silicon Valley the
reason many of these firms couldn't make
payroll in Silicon Valley out in
California was because they had all of
their money in this one place and it
means if that one place has a problem
you can't do the simple things banks are
supposed to do which is help you run
your business help you pay your mortgage
help you do the very simple things so
you know a lot of us have money coming
in on a schedule usually a paycheck and
we pay bills on a schedule also and that
can make it easier to plan but when it
comes to money a lot of people don't
like surprises
so surprises could come around sort of
at any time as you expect it's a
surprise and so what we talked to most
the financial advisors said keep three
to six months of dry powder three to six
months of your expenses in an account
that's ready to pay I would say this as
well the thing that happens in an
emergency is you're not also thinking
about the the mental toll it's going to
take on you and so having it in
complicated places can be even more
difficult and so having three to six
months in money where you're not having
to move it around you're not going to
have to make a whole bunch of decisions
if something really happens to you your
partner yourself you're going to want to
know where that capital is you're not
going to want to have to make 40
different changes to get that money you
know in a lot of cases the FDIC will
protect people if something happens to
their money that's held at a bank but
how about running your money through a
test to be sure you're getting an ideal
return on your Holdings where can people
start yeah I mean the easiest thing is
know what your return is if you're in a
checking account and you're getting
nothing or you're in a savings account
at a bank and getting enough effect know
that there are ways to improve the
return on your capital a money market
savings account today at a brokerage is
going to yield you over four percent if
you're getting nothing in your checking
account and there's thirty thousand
dollars sitting there doing nothing
you're just giving away money there's
other things high yield savings accounts
have been really beneficial online we've
seen a rise in people buying CDs this is
guaranteed money this is not like
putting money in the stock market where
it could go up or down in six months
you're gonna get this money back we
talked to financial advisors which they
say over and over again the biggest
mistake people have is way too much
money in their checking account that's
money that can be put to work in return
and if you are really concerned about
taxes you're saying look I love getting
a return of four percent but I don't
want to pay heavy taxes on this I don't
want to you know come at the end of the
year really drives my tax bill higher I
would really suggest municipal bonds
bank rate has data that says the average
American sticks with their primary
checking and savings account for about
17 years on average it's interesting
because when we buy a home we shop for
like 30 different mortgage rates we're
trying to get the best rate we buy
mortgage broker who goes it's like I'm
going to get half of a basis point
better than this other person so we go
with them and yet we put our checking
account in and completely go on
autopilot the same rigor you might have
done to get your home loan is something
you should look at your bank regularly
is your bank providing a good enough
return to your savings account what's
your customer service like if your
customer service is not great you can
change Banks you are not picking a bank
for life you know in terms of running
your money through these tests and
trying to find the best opportunity if
somebody has a 401k account how would
that fit into this idea of testing to
gauge the strength of their investments
in this kind of environment it's really
important to look at what you're
investing in your 401k and I think if
you cut your investments into your 401k
and you cut it below your company's
match then you're making a mistake you
should do whatever it takes to get the
free money that your company is
providing after that it is discretionary
money if you need it now and you made a
decision six months ago or a year ago to
cut your investment of 401k okay because
there were things you had to pay for and
it could be inflation I know a lot of
people the rising cost of child care
forced them to say you know for a couple
years I'm going to lower my 401k so I
have money to pay for a 2 000 a month
child care for my second kid or whatever
it is a lot of people made that decision
that is not a decision that should be
made forever and little changes to your
401k can go a big way let's say you cut
it down to six percent can you afford
seven we're not saying you need to go
back to the 10 you had before kids but
maybe just add a percent if you can do
it it's going to be beneficial you'll
thank yourself in your 60s and I think
that now you sort of have to realize how
comfortable are your job how comfortable
you are with inflation and if you say
you're doing a little bit better and
you're feeling like you're saving a
little money I might think about if you
cut down to the bone maybe add a little
bit more meat maybe go this again you
don't have to go all the way to ten
seven percent can make a big difference
and I think we're starting to see some
people do that all right that's the Wall
Street journalist Jeff rogo with us Jeff
thanks so much for being with us on the
show thank you for having me and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
thank you